[Musique]
je suis revenue en corée du sud en
pleine floraison des cerisiers mais
aussi autant de lakovic 19 alors c'est
seulement depuis une fenêtre que j'ai pu
en apercevoir quelques uns au début de
mon séjour depuis le balcon d'une
chambre où j'ai passé deux semaines en
isolement et c'est obligatoire pour
quiconque arrive en corée du sud
jusqu'à nouvel ordre aucun décès lié au
corps d'un virus de bilans quotidiens
une première pour produire des
reportages en confinement je peux
heureusement compter sur mes formidable
fixeur traducteur journalistes et
recherchiste plus indispensable que
jamais alors ici à séoul je peux compter
sur driss à pékin et sa déjà depuis
plusieurs années sur enzo et
dernièrement sur jacob à roanne
ils sont véritablement mes yeux est mise
hors et sur les 1 600 bureaux et au
canada en corée du sud
[Musique]
composer avec les moyens du bord
ça veut dire aussi une seule prise
électrique qui fonctionne c'est notre
correspondante à nîmes 0 et sur place
annick et au moment d'aller à l'antenne
comme ici le soir au canada déjà le
lendemain matin en corée du sud
le wifi et la 4g font souvent des
caprices je crois que nous avons perdu à
nyc & communication sont toujours assez
difficile ces temps ci c'est parce qu'il
ya trop de monde en même temps sur les
réseaux nous dit on dans cet
établissement gouvernemental qui est
converti en centre de confinement pour
ceux et celles qui n'ont pas d'adressé
fixe en corée du sud
enfin béraud par contre est-ce qui est
régulier réglé comme du papier à musique
c'est la prise de température de toutes
les personnes en quarantaine matin et
soir et ce même si le test de dépistage
que j'ai subie à mon arrivée s'est avéré
négatif
et c'était à peu près les seules
personnes avec lesquelles je peut
interagir face à face enfin masque à
masquer des gens toujours courtois mais
toujours distants
j'ai aussi pour consigne de faire un
auto diagnostic quotidien avec une
application téléchargée à l'aéroport
fièvre mal de gorge
autre symptôme a rapporté en quelques
clics les résultats sont soumis aux
autorités sanitaires
il faut également essayer de bouger un
peu ne serait ce que pour garder la
forme et surtout ne pas perdre la tête
autant que faire se peut mais
interdiction stricte de quitter la
chambre sous peine de sanctions prison
amende
expulsion d'ailleurs on nous le répète
souvent ça fait partie des messages qui
sont diffusées par interphone plusieurs
fois par jour en plusieurs langues
le menu lui varie peu
les repas sont livrés trois fois par
jour il arrive froid même ceux qui ont
été cuisinés devant la quarantaine
personne n'entre dans novembre pour
faire le ménage
encore moins pour vider les poubelles on
nous a donné des directives très
précises nos déchets sont traités comme
s'ils étaient contaminés
[Applaudissements]
enfin franchir le seuil de 7 chambres
pour la première fois en 15 jours et
chaque pilote de passage obligé dans
cette corée du sud qui veulent réduire
le nombre de cas de contamination qu'il
appelle importés
[Musique]